in business uh i've lost a lot in the
last you know 21 years of being in the
financial industry it's a very very
competitive i've lost a lot of clients
to other companies i've lost agents i've
lost employees i've lost contracts
and
you know it was very easy to say well
you know in the industry today
uh you know it's because i'm armenian
it's because i'm from iran one time i
lost the contract to a big company
because they were concerned i was
armenian and you know uh uh what do you
call it there was a couple armenian
insurance frauds going on in glendale
and they said you're part of that
community i said no here's where i'm at
this is my business is this model so
well we had a bad experience because we
had a two million dollar charge back i
said no i said i want you to judge me
for who i am i don't want you to judge
me for what my ethnicity is let's see
this and let's see what we can do and i
want to compete and i kept our contract
we're best best friends still today the
same people that were going to drop my
contract 11 years ago they had me at
their retirement ceremony